- It's not like it's
happening what you're saying
in the movies, where it's like...
(woman hums)
- Alright.
- It's just a movement,
it's a swift, quick...
- And that doesn't like...
(woman shouts out)
- She's a fucking child.
- For some people, there's
nothing better than
putting on your finest, cosiest sleepwear
before you head off to dreamland.
But there's other people...
they just let it all hang out.
Butts, boobs, balls...
Sleeping naked. It's debatable.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Keith, and I think you should sleep
with some clothes on.
- I'm Colin and I'm not a goddamn puritan.
- Team naked.
- Team clothes.
- You should not sleep naked.
- Let's get naked.
(dramatic music)
- The case for clothes.
Well, in my mind, the case
has already been closed.
- Let's say you have a roommate.
Let's say you live with
other people and you wake up
in the middle of the
night and you need water.
Are you going to be just naked there?
- The thing is, your body
is always churning out,
it's always working, so of
course you're going to fart.
You know, toot toot
toot. You know, (puffs).
- Two easy solutions for that.
Do your fucking laundry,
wipe your fucking ass.
- Even just a little boxer brief
is going to catch some
of them poo particles.
Keep them out of that bed,
you know what I'm saying?
It's going to help. Yes, it's
going to help. Don't say no.
- I would argue that it's
actually more comfortable
to wear clothes while you sleep.
- The more layers you have
while you're sleeping,
the more control you have
over your temperature.
- It's easier to take off
clothes than to put them back on.
- If you're a pajama pal...
You know, you pick out
some nice, silky pajamas.
You soak your way through them.
Maybe you've got lots of silky pajamas
you can put on; that's nice.
- I want to create the
optimal sleeping experience,
and with that comes
control, and the control
of having articles of clothing.
- I feel like all of your problems
would be solved with just another blanket.
- That's a blanket answer
to a specific problem.
- Yeah, you can stack on
more and more blankets,
but it would... oh, boohoo, Colin,
you're going to boohoo me, you're going
to boohoo me right here,
right here on camera?
- God forbid there was a fire.
- If my apartment was on fire,
I would not give a flying
fuck if I was naked.
I would probably die.
- Because you're looking
for something to put on
before you leave the house.
- No, I'm looking for my cats.
- [Garrett] Yes.
I don't know how to argue with her.
She just takes the children's
way out of every argument.
- (laughs) I drive a car. I'm an adult.
- Also, if you sleep with another person,
especially if you're sleeping,
like, with your brother
over Christmas holiday, you
should not be sleeping naked.
- OK, OK, you're not going to sleep
naked with your buddies or your family.
Obviously, you make some
concessions, alright.
I'm not an animal.
(dramatic music)
Is there anything on this planet
more comfortable than nothing?
- Silk.
- The sensation of being naked,
just swimming in your sheets, is one of
the greatest pleasures on Earth.
- Have you seen Eastern Promises?
The naked fights? They're the best!
- When else do your bits and
pits ever see the light of day,
and have a chance to
just see the elements.
- That is a cartoonish
argument and you know it.
- You sleep in a crisp
cold, you wake up refreshed.
You sleep in too much
heat, you wake up feeling
like you've been in the
goddamn laundry machine.
- Mm mm, you sleep in the
crisp cold, you wake up
with a sinus infection,
and that's the truth.
- What most often happens
when I start the night
wearing clothes is I overheat, and then,
in the middle of the night, I rage-quit,
and I shed the layers, and I'm like,
"Oh, I wish I'd started
the night like this.
"Because then I wouldn't be drowning
"in a pool of my own sweat right now."
- That helps you get confident
with your body, walking around naked.
It feels good, just
feels good to be naked.
- I'd get naked right now if
it wasn't an HR violation.
- OK.
- Sex is easier this way.
When you're already naked.
- That's true, but you miss
a very fun part of foreplay,
which is disrobing the partner.
- One last barrier.
- Clothes are not the most
tricky thing to get past.
Like right now, I can get to
my stomach in a heartbeat.
- Overheating leads to restlessness.
Restlessness leads to insomnia.
I would be getting so much worse sleep
if I was wearing clothes,
but I'm deciding to
put my health first, and
my best interests first,
and do what's best for
my circadian rhythms.
(dramatic music)
- We've had a productive debate today.
I've learnt a lot about Steven.
I think he's learnt a
little too much about me.
- I think the argument is
I'm for an extra barrier.
- You should feel free to sleep naked.
Like, me sleeping clothed
does not impact you at all,
and you sleeping naked would
not impact me at all, either.
- Unless we slept together.
- Keep it smooth, no bunchin'.
- Safety, comfort, and,
at the end of the day, relaxation.
(dramatic music)
- You think that a fart is the same
as a poop poop. Colin, please.
- Did you just do a Cosby?
- I try. (laughs) It's a habit I got.
I got upset and I just pulled a Cosby.
In the old meaning of the word.